peter après une mesure similaire de
washington à l'encontre du consulat de
chine à houston les tensions
sino-américaines à leur comble
cessez le feu dans l'est de l'ukraine en
vigueur depuis tout à l'heure
nouvel espoir pour une solution
politique à ce conflit qui dure depuis
six ans moscou appelle la nécessité pour
toutes les parties de respecter les
accords de meetic
[Musique]
très bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
très heureux de vous retrouver sur arte
france pour 30 minutes d'information
retour du projet de loi bioéthique au
palais bourbon au sein du texte
l'ouverture de la pm à la procréation
médicalement assistée à toutes les
femmes quelques 2300 aux amendements
doivent être examinées jusqu'à la fin de
la semaine
le point depuis l'assemblée nationale
avec katia pique nique terroristes c'est
une semaine clef pour le projet de loi
sur la bioéthique examiné à partir
d'aujourd'hui
et pourtant l'hémicycle est plus que
clairsemé un projet controversé
toutefois le sénat a donné son aval pour
le principe de la pma pour tout c'est à
dire ouverts aux fameux lesbiennes et
aux femmes célibataires mais certaines
mesures avaient été expurgé par les
sénateurs elle ont été réintroduites par
une commission spéciale aujourd'hui le
ministre de la santé olive et veyran le
garde des sceaux eric dupond moretti et
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche
frédéric vidal sont venus défendre les
mesures olive et veyran a expliqué qu'il
souhaitait ouvrir le droit à toutes les
femmes à la pma pour tout depuis de
nombreuses années et que pour se
construire un enfant avait peut-être
besoin d'un référent familial mais
surtout d'amour je vous propose de
l'écouter
je ne sais pas si la famille est un
point de repère sans doute ce que je
sais en tout cas c'est qu'elle est
toujours un point de départ
point de départ de la vie d'un individu
point de départ de la construction d'un
citoyen est le seul point de départ qui
compte quand on est jetés dans
l'existence c'est l'amour de celles et
ceux qui vous accueille
voilà le seul équilibre qui devrait nous
préoccuper peu du côté de la
mobilisation citoyenne et bien la
réponse était faible aujourd'hui puisque
seulement 25 militants environ de la
famille dite traditionnelle sont venus
protester aux alentours de l'assemblée
nationale en revanche du côté des
députés de l'opposition et bien la
colère est grande puisque il estime que
la loi et heures examiné en catimini à
une date peu approprié olivet verront
s'en est défendu puisqu'il n'a pas
souhaité at il dit de procédure
accélérée
en tout cas les députés n'auront que 25
heures pour examiner plus de deux mille
amendements dont certains très
controversé maximino est l'un des rares
députés des régions
l'équipe favorable à la pma pour toute
ils appellent à légiférer il y a une
particularité qui rassemble toutes les
femmes qui ont déjà bénéficié d'une pma
pour tout c'est qu'elles ont les moyens
de le faire les moyens d'aller à
l'étranger de pouvoir payer se payer le
transport pour partir à l'étranger de se
loger sur place de pouvoir effectivement
faire appel à une clinique étrangères
tout ça c'est un coup et aujourd'hui
toutes ces femmes elles ont cette
particularité c'est qu'elles peuvent se
payer le moyen de le faire donc il y as
a d'une part une égalité au social et
puis il ya des risques sanitaires
derrière tout ça aujourd'hui j'ai appris
tellement de choses pendant cette
commission spéciale pendant toutes ses
auditions sur la pma pour tout d'une
part des femmes dans un tel désespoir de
vouloir procréer on était amené à
acheter du sperme sur internet et de se
faire d insémination artisanale à la
maison est bien là je dis que
législateur doit intervenir il doit
intervenir tout simplement pour
légaliser tout cela de façon à ce que à
cesser ces risques sanitaires
donc il y a effectivement plein de
facteurs emmanuel macron l'avez
peut-être effectivement mis dans son
campagne dans son plan de campagne pour
les présidentielles mais aujourd'hui il
faut mettre de côté la politique
politicienne il faut agir pour la
société est aujourd'hui moi en tant que
député on me demande de faire quoi de
faire une loi juste équitable pour
toutes et pour tous
et aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment que ça
remet sur un pied d'égalité dessous des
femmes luttent contre les passoires
thermiques fin des terrasses chauffées
après le prochain hiver fin des
chaudières au fioul ou au charbon
ce sont les premières mesures issues de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
le conseil écologique le cinquième du
nom s'est tenue ce matin à l'elysée
avant les lois en cours de rédaction il
en est donc sorti quelques mesures qui
peuvent être mises en oeuvre rapidement
par décret ou par arrêté on écoute la
ministre de la transition écologique par
bach a conquis vie et mesures retenues
s'inscrivent dans les trois axes
identifiés par les sites
du coup se loger la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments
la maîtrise de la consommation d'énergie
et la lutte contre l'artificialisation
des sols
le conseil a enfin permis d'accélérer
notre progression vers l'objectif fixé
par le président de la république de
placer 30 % du territoire national sous
protection
donc là on parle de biodiversité ce
n'était pas dans le champ de compétence
de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat mais je vous rappelle que nous
sommes dans un conseil de défense
écologique et donc nous touchons au delà
des questions climatiques
toutes les questions environnementales
le secteur du bâtiment représente
notamment à cause du chauffage près de
20% des émissions de co2 de notre pays
à cela s'ajoute qu'une bonne isolation
des logements permet de mieux lutter
contre les canicule qui frappe de plus
en plus fréquemment notre pays
c'est un outil majeur de résilience face
aux changements climatiques une base
miso l'action ça permet notamment par
exemple dans les ehpad de pouvoir avoir
des pièces fraîches par tous les enjeux
sont également sociaux et sanitaires
nous comptons encore autour de 5
millions de passoires thermiques en
france dont 200 milles sont des
logements sociaux mais toujours
concernant le climat jean castex annonce
la création d'autoroutes ferroviaires
objectif relancer le fret
deux axes avancée par matignon bayonne
charbourg et cette galette
le premier ministre annonce également la
réouverture de la ligne perpignan rungis
l'exécutif qui conseille aux entreprises
de se constituer un stock de masques
pour 10 semaines en cas de résurgence de
la pandémie de coronavirus une
recommandation déjà faite
début juillet les renouveler dans un
contexte de rebond du nombre de
nouvelles contaminations plus de 1000
cas journalier lors des derniers jours
parmi les autres mesures mises en place
pour prévenir une deuxième vague lé
pompier secouriste aides soignants et
étudiants en santé sont autorisés en
réalité à réaliser des tests arrêté
publié ce week-end au journal officiel
une décision condamnée notamment par les
infirmiers t'es pas un geste anodin que
ça s'est réalisé
cp serre et je doute un peu que les
personnes comme des secouristes ou des
aides soignants qui n'ont jamais réalisé
ce type d'actes soient à l'aise avec
avec ça et alors dans certaines
situations pourquoi pas pour ça que je
ne l'exclus pas après je pense que
je pense qu'on pourrait mieux utiliser
les infirmiers en leur permettrant et
bien tout simplement comme je vous ai
tout à l'heure de d'utiliser les
infirmiers éventuellement hospitalier ou
qui travaillent dans le privé en
clinique pour venir dans nos cabinets de
ville pour nous aider et actuellement ça
c'est impossible par la réglementation
actuelle est donc peut-être qu'il aurait
fallu ou qu'il faudrait en parallèle
nous autoriser à embaucher des
infirmiers en vacation pour pouvoir nous
aider dans nos cabinets de ville et dans
les laboratoires de ville avec qui on
travaille
et cette question qui revient souvent
ces derniers temps comment les
populations juge-t-elle la gestion de la
crise sanitaire par leur gouvernement
une étude internationale conduite dans
six pays par le cabinet qu'ex 106 et il
a tenté d'y répondre
[Musique]
arnaud benedetti est le rédacteur en
chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire il estime que l'état a été
si contradictoires dans ses annonces en
raison de la science elle-même
incertaine
on a eu et ça a été relevé par nombre de
commentateurs et d'observateurs de
multiples injonctions contradictoires
qui ont été produites par les autorités
politiques et les autres les autorités
sanitaires
la question des masques en étant me
semble-t-il l'illustration la plus
incandescente puisque on nous a dit en
début de pandémie que le masque n'était
pas nécessaire puis ensuite qu'il était
est nécessaire et aujourd'hui on le rend
obligatoire dans les lieux clos donc
cette instabilité de la parole publique
n'a certainement pas dix ont permis à
l'opinion publique de disposer d'une
très grande confiance dans l'action des
pouvoirs publics
c'est un fait certainement extrêmement
extrêmement important mais il y a aussi
dit la réalité c'est que la parole
politique la parole publique la parole
de l'état était indexée sur les
incertitudes de la parole scientifique
et de la parole médical elle même donc
cette incertitude de la parole
scientifique cette incertitude de la
parole médical qui est tout à fait
encore une fois compréhensible par
rapport à un virus que l'on ne connaît
pas à peser lourdement sur la
communication au public
washington/pekin un énième épisode les
tensions diplomatiques sino-américaines
que jamais à leur comble les autorités
chinoises prennent possession du
consulat de chengdu représailles à la
mesure similaire prise par washington à
l'encontre de la représentation
diplomatique chinoise au texas il ya 48
heures théo combat
la bannière étoilée qui disparaît les
emblèmes des états unis démonter la
prise de possession du désormais ex
consulat américain de kindu par pékin
symbolise le dernier acte des tensions
sino-américaines source de cette mesure
de rétorsion la fermeture du consulat de
chine à houston vendredi
washington accuse la mission
diplomatique d'être une plaque tournante
de l'espionnage chinois
objectif selon la maison blanche
protéger la propriété intellectuelle et
les informations privées des américains
le président trump a dit ça suffit nous
n'allons pas permettre que cela se
produise à nouveau
vous avez vu les remarques du conseiller
à la sécurité nationale au brian du
directeur du fbi à ivry du procureur
général bart nous avons défini des
attentes claires quant à la manière dont
le parti communiste chinois devrait se
comporter et lorsqu'ils ne le fera pas
nous adopterons des mesures pour
protéger le peuple américain
notre sécurité notre sécurité nationale
et aussi notre économie et nos emplois
ce sont les mesures que vous voyez le
président trump adopté et nous
continuerons à le faire
la réponse chinoise ne s'est donc pas
fait attendre et le message de pékin se
veut très clair la situation actuelle
entre la chine et les états unis n'est
pas ce que souhaite la chine les etats
unis sont responsables de tout cela
encore une fois nous demandons aux états
unis de revenir immédiatement sur leurs
mauvaises décisions et de créer les
conditions nécessaires pour remettre les
relations bilatérales sur de bons rails
des relations extrêmement dégradée et ce
depuis plusieurs mois ambitions
chinoises en mer de chine
la question des ouigours accusations
américaines concernant la gestion du
coronavirus par la chine
sans oublier la bataille entre les deux
pays concernant la 5g ou encore la
multiplication des sanctions économiques
américaines
les motifs de conflits se multiplient
entre les deux superpuissances une
montée en tension continue qui ne semble
pas prêt de s'apaiser
quelles conséquences concrètement de ce
nouvel épisode de tension éléments de
réponse avec jean vincent brisset ch
directeur de recherche à l'iris et
spécialiste de là
alors le dépenser dans de multiples il
ya les problèmes de l'eau massy et de
l'économie mais surtout les problèmes
d'économie pour le moment parce que là
où la chine de la plus vénérable c'est
dans ce domaine là et c'est aussi d'être
quelque chose dont les états unis ofit
en particulier l'administration fin
puisque il est difficile aux candidats
bind de se battre contre 1 pas ce niveau
là les démocrates qui ont été les
premiers au d'année à sa prime de choses
de la part de la chine
donc si tron comprendre la vence dans ce
domaine là les démocrates où on se
retrouve en position de suivi elle a
pris pour un navire russe a montré que
la chine avait triché dans un 52e
domaine en plus une mauvaise gestion
pour une fois à l'international pour la
non de la crise dans le fait qu elle ne
l est permis par son système de gestion
sanitaire de cette crise arrive on peut
reprocher donc effectivement là le
coupable de la crise du cordat virus et
la chine nourrit par une politique
extérieure américaine marquée par des
tensions diplomatiques donc à une
politique intérieure secoué par le
mouvement black live made her retour sur
les dernières heures émaillés de
violences notamment au texas où un
manifestant a été tué avec grace d'asia
un rassemblement qui tourne au drame à
austin au texas
samedi soir un manifestant a été abattu
à bout portant par un automobiliste
ce dernier est entré dans la foule au
volant de son véhicule pour des raisons
encore inconnues le conducteur aurait
tiré plusieurs coups de feu sur la
victime
garrett foster un militant d'une
trentaine d'années connu pour ses propos
virulents envers la police et les
personnalités politiques sur la toile le
suspect a été arrêté par les forces de
l'ordre peu avant dans l'après midi
toujours au texas à westford alors que
des manifestants du mouvement black
light madder exigeait le déboulonnement
de la statue d'un confédérés des contre
manifestants dont certains étaient armés
les ont agressés 1 contre manifestants
accusés d'avoir attaqué plusieurs
militants a ainsi été arrêtée et à
portland ce sont toujours les mêmes
scènes depuis plusieurs semaines des
manifestants qui tentent de faire céder
la barrière du palais de justice une
clôture devenu le symbole d'un fossé
toujours plus profond entre la
population et les agents fédéraux dont
la présence et les méthodes sont très
contestées par les manifestants
il veut qu hollande arrive quelque part
avec toutes ces protestations les gens
essaient d'obtenir des changements
systémiques des changements réels au
sein du gouvernement et tout ça c'est
tout à fait ce que je veux voir
je ne veux pas avoir à continuer à
protester pour la vie des noirs vous
comprenez il y a une ligne et d'anciens
combattants et je suis un ancien
combattant et j'ai voulu venir au côté
de sega et je voulais aller voir ces
fédéraux quel qu'il soit
flic ou agents ou quoi qu'il soit et
leur dire hey mec sergent koval armée de
l'air américaine
ancien combattant du vietnam et merci
d'être ici et de faire votre devoir
mais je suis vraiment désolé je pense
que vous avez le pire de voir au monde
et je pense que vous le savez
arrestations arbitraires voiture
banalisée tenues paramilitaires et sans
badge d'identification visible
les méthodes des agents fédéraux de
diviser sont souvent dénoncé comme étant
la cause du courroux des contestataires
du côté de chicago la mer est
catégorique
j'ai été très clair ça n'arrivera pas à
chicago
nous n'avons pas besoin de troupes
fédérales nous n'avons pas besoin
d'agents fédéraux secrets et non
identifié qui rôdent dans les rues de
chicago
ce n'est pas la démocratie que nous
avons vu se déployer dans les rues de
portland à la suite de l'intervention
fédérale
c'est ce qu'on appelle la tyrannie et la
dictature et nous n'en voulons pas à
chicago je crains une enquête du
ministère de la justice a été ouverte
jeudi sur les méthodes très controversée
des agents fédéraux
en attendant les manifestations quasi
quotidiennes contre les violences
policières et le racisme systémique se
poursuivent à travers tous les pays
nouveau cessez le feu en vigueur depuis
tout à l'heure dans l'est de l'ukraine
un nouvel espoir de relancer le
processus de paix dans cette région en
proie à la guerre depuis six ans la
situation dans le donbass au coeur d'un
échange téléphonique ir entre le
président russe vladimir poutine et son
homologue ukrainien volodimir zelensky
moscou insiste sur l'importance du
respect sans condition des accords de
minsk la correspondance en russie signé
anthony lerew pour les belligérants mais
avant tout pour la population de l'est
de l'ukraine cela représente l'espoir
l'espoir d'un répit l'espoir que cesse
enfin les hostilités en effet les deux
présidents se sont unis hier au
téléphone principalement afin de faire
le point sur la situation dans le
donbass se sont félicités de ce
cessez-le-feu je cite complet et global
à l'ensemble de la région qui fait
partie du plan de route des accords de
minsk signé en 2015 une trêve dont on
d'ores et déjà pris acte les parties
prenantes au conflit
en vertu des accords négociés par le
groupe de contact tripartite à minsk le
22 juillet 2020 nous procédons à un
cessez-le-feu au complet et indéfinie
l'ensemble du personnel de la milice
populaire à l'interdiction du
des armes quelles qu'elles soient y
compris de petits calibres à partir du
27 juillet 2020 à 00h01
sur instruction du chef de la république
populaire de deux nièces
le département de la milice populaire a
émis un ordre pertinents qui a été
dûment soumis pour la signature à toutes
les unités et à chaque soldat
concrètement ce cessez-le-feu a été
obtenue à la suite d'une réunion du
groupe de contact la semaine dernière et
qui a convenu de mesures supplémentaires
pour contrôler le respect de la trêve
reste à espérer que ces mesures
supplémentaires suffisent car toutes les
précédentes tentatives de cessez-le-feu
n'ont hélas pas duré bien longtemps
de son côté volodymyr céline ce qui a
particulièrement insisté sur la
nécessité de poursuivre la libération
des ressortissants ukrainiens je cite
détenus dans le donbass en crimée et en
russie vladimir poutine s'est pour sa
part dit préoccupé par une loi récemment
adoptée par le parlement ukrainien qui
ouvre la voie à des élections régionales
en 2022
ce qui est d'après lui contraire aux
accords de minsk et met en danger les
perspectives de règlement du conflit
les deux présidents finalement se sont
entendus pour dire qu'il était
prioritaire de mettre en oeuvre les
résolutions prises à paris lors du
sommet reforma normandie 2 décembre
dernier beaucoup de bonnes intentions
donc à voir maintenant comment la
situation va évoluer sur le terrain
réactions tout un ordi porte parole du
kremlin qui évoque une étape importante
le fait que les autorités des
républiques autoproclamées devient
ridicule et dans l'eure des créances
fait c'est le chemin des fumiers c'est
une décision très louable est
satisfaisante
c'est un grand pas vers le renforcement
de la confiance mutuelle et vers une
baisse des tensions dans ce cas ce
serait important que les deux parties
respecte complètement ses obligations et
accor
en ce qui concerne l'atmosphère de la
conversation téléphonique entre vladimir
poutine et volodymyr hellemmes ce qu
elle est constructive et sérieuse du la
teneur de la conversation et de riches
julian assange espionner comme dans un
film affirmations de l'avocat espagnol
du fondateur de wikileaks auditionné
aujourd'hui à madrid
balthazar carson entendu après avoir
porté plainte contre la société
espagnole chargée de la sécurité à
l'ambassade équateur à londres où j'ai
un sens j'étais réfugié selon lui micros
et caméras était caché jusque dans les
toilettes pour femmes où le lanceur
d'alert organisait des réunions par
souci de confidentialité
il accuse l'entreprise d'avoir espionné
l'australien pour le compte de
washington
ils m'ont montré des images où nous les
avocats parlons à julian les appareils
des coûts que les appareils de
surveillance vidéo et d'enregistrement
c'est quelque chose de scandaleux
quelque chose qui n'arrive que dans les
films d'espionnage mais ceci n'est pas
un film d'espionnage
[Musique]
car la vie d'une personne est en jeu un
journaliste tout ce qui a été fait est
une persécution contre un journaliste le
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks pour
avoir rendu publics des faits terribles
des crimes contre l'humanité et des
processus de corruption le choc de
commissions l'agent de la persécution ce
sont les états unis ils n'ont pas
renoncé de notre point de vue ce qu'ils
font est totalement illégal et ils ont
dans ce cas utiliser une société de
sécurité qui par l'intermédiaire de son
plus haut représentant rapporter
régulièrement et méticuleusement tout ce
que l'équipe de défense faisait la
justice britannique suspend l'audience
d'extradition de julian assange qui
devait avoir lieu aujourd'hui à londres
le lanceur d' alerte aurait dû être
entendu via visioconférence depuis la
prison où il est emprisonné aimait les
responsables pénitenciers affirme ne pas
avoir été mis au courant de l'audience
finalement ajourné de nombreux soutiens
julian assange se sont réunis malgré
tout devant le tribunal tout à l'heure
nous étions tous dans un état de
confusion ne savions pas vraiment ce qui
se passait il est soudainement apparu
que la prison n'était pas au courant
qu'ils étaient censés comparaître par
vidéoconférence
ce qui est une affirmation bizarre car
ils ont cette date depuis longtemps
atteint donc vraiment personne n'était
complètement sur celle s'agissait
simplement d'une confusion ou de quelque
chose de plus sinistre que cela une
tentative d' embrouiller l'esprit de
chacun d'envoyer son esprit le service
des poursuites judiciaires de la
couronne reçois des messages très mitigé
de la part des procureurs américains qui
sont en retard mais on n'en pas présenté
au tribunal ou à la défense les
nouvelles demandes d'extradition de
julian nous préciser sur quelles
accusations exactement cela montre et
nous sommes maintenant à la fin du mois
de juillet que leur dossier s'effondre
de jour en jour fermeté de la cedeao
vis-à-vis du mali les quinze dirigeants
de la communauté des états de l'afrique
de l'ouest réunis cet après midi via
visioconférence menace de brandir des
sanctions contre les opposants président
ibrahim boubacar keïta le plan de sortie
de crise prévoit le maintien au pouvoir
dit beckham et il prône la constitution
rapide d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale incluant l'opposition et des
élections législatives partielles la
cedeao exige également la démission de
31 députés mal élu le mali a aujourd'hui
besoin d'une assemblée nationale
conforme aux résultats des élections
législatives d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale d'une nouvelle cour
constitutionnelle et d'une enquête sur
les événements des 10 11 et 12 juillet
on reste en afrique avec le soudan
nouvelle tuerie au darfour quelques 500
hommes armés ont mené un raid meurtrier
contre un village habité par des
agriculteurs 60 personnes ont été tuées
les maisons brûlées et pillé c'est le
simple le septième incident en près
d'une semaine dans la région en proie à
des violences depuis de nombreuses
années
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
l'analyse de marc lavergne il est
directeur de recherche au cnrs et
spécialiste de la corne de l'afrique
c'est d'abord un conflit en autour de la
terre autour des récoltes à venir autour
des villages des habitations
c'est un conflit de légitimité entre des
gens qui ont été chassés qui sont
revenus et maintenant d'autres qui
devraient de nouveau s'approprier leurs
terres je crois pas qu'on puisse
qualifier ça de conflits ethniques au
sens propre c'est simplement un conflit
peut-être on peut dire entre des
agriculteurs et des éleveurs pasteurs
nomades 1 donc il ya des animaux qui ont
besoin de pâturage qui ont besoin d'eau
et qui traverse cette région à la saison
des pluies pour aller chercher des
pâturages nous honore mais sur le seul
mois ils peuvent gêner la les travaux
des champs des paysans
1 c'est essentiellement ce à un autre
aspect qui explique cette violence
déchaînée
c'est le fait que la région est
maintenant submergé par les armes à feu
à cause des conflits qu'il ya autour un
à la fois en libye et puis donc
tellement au tchad le fait que les
jeunes de la région sont embauchés pour
faire la guerre au yémen tout ça apporte
beaucoup d'argent sur cette région et
beaucoup de violence
le hezbollah joue avec le feu propos ce
soir signé benyamin netanyahou alors qu
israël déclarent avoir déjoué une
tentative d'infiltration terroriste à la
frontière nord avec le liban l'armée
israélienne évoque des combats dans la
région du monde venant israélien du mont
hermon occupés par israël et revendique
et de longue date par le liban d' il ya
quelques heures salle a ordonné à la
population vivant sur le plateau du
golan et le long de la frontière avec le
liban de rester chez elles après je cite
un incident en de sécurité l'onu appelle
à la plus grande retenue
voilà c'est la fin de ce jt merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dans 30
minutes d'ici là reste évidemment sur
arte
[Musique]
vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir au terme
d'un imbroglio politique d'une
présidentielle contestée dans les
élections qui avaient les observateurs
la cedeao l'union européenne et tous ces
gens ont confirmé que les élections nous
formons discipline démocratiques
transparentes qui a gagné c'est le
général omar sisaw cours d'un ballon
mais maladroit qui a certes un chef
d'état qui a voulu carrière des
pagailles en dynamisant si ça s'agite
pour moi aujourd'hui est jeune homme
d'état et ces gens là
l'histoire va les condamner en 45 en 16
tentatives de coup d'état quatre putschs
le dernier c'était en 2012 vous croyez
que c'est terminé
vous êtes en sursis le mot gènes gene
aucun opposant aujourd'hui guinée-bissau
aujourd'hui et la insight chef chez moi
[Musique]
le grave incident du digeon entre une
frégate française et des navires de
combat turc doit nous faire prendre
conscience de l'évolution inquiétante de
la situation en méditerranée orientale
nous sommes confrontés un président
tuerie qui résonne exclusivement en
rapport de me considérer l'europe comme
un adversaire qu'il a toujours réussi à
faire plier en pariant qu'il n'y aura
jamais d escalade avec des alliés il
continue à affirmer une ligne
diplomatico militaire indépendant par
rapport à ses alliés de l'otan tout en
se déclarant un membre totalement fiable
de cet organisme
la négociation sera difficile avec un
interlocuteur qui n'hésite pas à se
mettre sur la ligne rouge pour forcer le
destin
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifiques parlent commun